at windsor castle
preparations were building up
the military carrying out final
rehearsals for the funeral that'll take
place
entirely behind castle walls
30 people will make up the congregation
with the duke's children and
grandchildren
represented in the procession to the
chapel led by the prince of wales
and princess anne the queen will be
accompanied by a lady in waiting as
she's driven behind the coffin
memphis the family will not wear
military uniform
and the congregation will be socially
distanced will wear face masks
and won't sing the irony of covid is
that the duke of edinburgh
who never liked all the panoply and
state wanted
no dramas about his dying and this
is the event that perhaps he would have
most required
it is measured it is tidy it is
disciplined
and it's the best salute the armed
forces could give
this will no doubt be the focal point
the unique mode of transport
chosen by the duke to carry his coffin a
land rover he
helped to design in a more traditional
touch
his insignia carefully sewn onto
cushions will be displayed inside the
chapel
representing the honours he received
throughout his lifetime
they represent british and commonwealth
orders and decorations and
the final cushion with orders from
greece and denmark for obvious reasons
there
are the the duke of edinburgh had i
think 61 decorations and awards from
53 different other countries and there
simply just wasn't the space
to have them all on display
this weekend the world will be watching
the royal family
and ultimately it was the queen who
decided that they won't be wearing
military uniform
the reason to try and keep the attention
on the duke of edinburgh
and away from problems they've had
recently within the family
and those who've stepped down from royal
duties
inevitably there will be interest in
prince william
and prince harry back together to mourn
their grandfather
walking in the same line behind his
coffin but separated by their
cousin peter phillips
in the privacy of marlborough house in
central london
where bouquets left at buckingham palace
have been moved
the prince of wales and the dutch of
cornwall looked at the flowers
and other fitting tributes left for his
father
the prince later spotted arriving at
windsor to support the queen
as the duke would have expected she's
supported variably by
the prince of wales who will continue to
do that in that role i think he will
carry on
um really as the main supporter to the
queen but the wider family would do that
too
but the prince of wales i think um
possibly will take on
if you like a more of a quasi-king role
whereby he will carry on like
international
trips and things like that representing
the queen
on saturday it will become clear just
how much
prince philip was involved in the
planning
from the music to military ceremony
making his mark
until the very end